are you surprising yourself with your
level at the moment I'm just Serena you
know yeah Serena Williams not exactly
shocked that she's playing so well at
the U.S open as fans family and famous
friends root on the goat
[Applause]
Serena clinched a win against the number
two player in the world Estonian tennis
pro Annette contavate after the match
Serena was asked about her Victory but
was kinda confused by the reporter's
question are you surprising yourself
with your level at the moment
what yeah uh head scratch element for
the champ are you surprising
ly with your level at the moment
what the reporter clarifies the question
and let's just say Serena delivered the
ultimate serve are you surprising
yourself with your level
no I know yeah that's when the reporter
realizes she probably already knew the
answer to that question
I'm just Serena you know so
I like to actually be the best at
whatever I do well I don't pretty good
player
uh you know I this is what I do best I
love a challenge and I'm rising to the
challenge Serena's win comes just weeks
after she told the world she's evolving
out of tennis but the question remains
when there's still a little left in me
we'll see the neck we'll see you know
it's it's no rush here I'm just uh I'm
loving this crowd and the crowd is
loving her right back
it was a star-studded event Tiger Woods
gave a signature fist pump in the stands
after Serena's win he tweeted it was a
privilege to watch greatness tiger sat
alongside Serena's sister Venus next to
them Vogue boss Anna Wintour and of
course Serena's hubby Alexis Ohanian was
showing all his love and support
experiencing in second hand uh
remarkable and here's their daughter
Olympia with Dad she
other celebs enjoying the event Zendaya
Gigi and Bella Hadid
the gravity when she jumps to the it's a
whole other
side you feel me I love you and Serena's
close pal LaLa Anthony
director Spike Lee also rallied in the
crowd and Anthony Anderson too
Pokemon
yep day three at the U.S open did not
disappoint and we have the goat to thank
for that
I'm just Serena you know so
[Applause]
[Music]